welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka homielander
in this video we're breaking down the a
train to z on everything we know about
season three of the boys
i'm so i'm sorry that a to z pun it
sounded a lot better in my head anyway
you're not here for the diabolical jokes
you want to know about season three and
we now have it confirmed that the third
entry will begin filming in february
2021.
the listing for the dates was posted on
the industry website
iatsc83 and claudia duma later revealed
the game's radar
that everything had been locked in and
that the date was set in stone
games radar dug deep on the info and
through the wayback machine they scanned
the website
and found that in october the schedule
changed from early 2021
to february to august this suggests that
the creative team have been planning
this out for quite some time now
and are ready to get the ball rolling
now the third season was actually
confirmed before the release of the
second
so it's clear that amazon knew they had
a hit on their hands and wanted to get
things in place as soon as possible
now using this information we can
predict the release of the upcoming show
if we look back at the past entries
gamesradar put together a big breakdown
on this which i'll link in the
description below
but looking back over the last couple of
years a pattern emerges which helps us
to estimate when we will finally get
some brand new episodes
now season 1 was filmed from may 2018
up until october of the same year and
the season then dropped on amazon in
july 2019
the second season film from july 2019 up
until november
and then the entry dropped in september
2020 so it took
five months to film the first season and
four to film the second
season one was released nine months
after the filming and season two
arrived after ten if the production of
season three
is 6 months and that means it's probably
gonna either be 10
or 11 months after it wraps up so we can
expect to see the boys either in june or
july of 2022
it sucks there's gonna be such a big gap
between the entries
and had the pandemic not happened we
would have likely seen the show this
time next year
hopefully they put a train in the
editing room or something er
having that yeah me neither now the
trailers for the show
tend to drop within six weeks of things
finishing up
so we will most likely get our first
look at the show around about this time
next year
now as for the first episode we do know
that it's gonna be called payback
and kripke confirmed this on twitter
recently by posting a picture of the
first page of the script
now there's a lot that we can take from
this and if you're a fan of the comics
then you'll
instantly recognize the name in the
source material payback are an
avengers-esque parody
that end up becoming some of the
storyline's biggest baddies
led by stormfront they attempt to attack
the boys but after butcher goes all
rambo on them
they're quickly defeated this leads to
stormfront fleeing the scene
and the ark culminates with the boys
kicking the crap out of him
and also while kicking it back into him
and i do think that this series will
divert quite a bit from it
as it's kind of done things out of order
i can actually see payback
reassembling and then going after the
boys to get some payback hey
now we know that jensen ackles is going
to be betraying soldier boy
and as he was also part of the group it
makes sense to go this route
anyone who knows what happens knows
we're in for a real treat with this
showdown
and we also have a lot of information on
which characters are coming back
now all of the members of the boys will
be reprising their roles
as will the majority of the seven whilst
we don't have definite answers on
whether aya cash will be making a return
we do know that stormfront did survive
the finale of the show
and that she is now currently in an
undisclosed location
now i kind of have gone back and forth
over where the stormfront will be
returning
as she was burned up pretty badly she
also lost her limbs
however as we learn from the series the
character gekko
is able to regrow his and as he works in
a lab in vote
it is possible that they will use him as
a way to develop this and then apply it
to the character
amazon did recently drop a new video to
tease soldier boy
and has cash featured in it it makes me
think that she could be back in some
form or another
however i think that ball will likely
want to keep her out the way
and thus she won't be the main
antagonist like she was in season two
on top of this we also know that
giancarlo esposito
has an extremely busy schedule over the
next year
so i imagine that he will be making
brief appearances similar to how he did
in season two
instead i think that the main focus will
be centered around soulja boy
homelander and victoria newman there's
potential
here for a lot of interesting dynamics
between the trio
as we know that vic works for vort that
soldier boy is going to be labeled as
the original homelander
in season 2 homelander was very
outspoken
about how volt needed him more than he
needed them
he also learned that he'd been betrayed
by them in the finale
and discovered that both mabe and
starlight were working for the other
side
so i think he could really fly off the
handle
in regards to vic claudia also said the
following
i'm excited to see what happens with
huey and her i'm excited to find out
more about her
and i'm excited to really dig into her
backstory and how she got to where she
is
also i'm very excited to see her eff
some issue
and blow up some heads so there is the
potential that we will be fully diving
into vic's backstory
and learning what her role in vote truly
is we did discover throughout the season
that vic had a daughter and
as ryan is the first ever naturally born
super child
it is possible that vor applied the
procedure to her after she had a child
and are now using her daughter as
leverage in order to get vic to work for
them
now what's interesting is that eric
kripke stated that soldier boy and
stormfront have a surprise connection to
one another
and the most obvious thing here is that
they are both part of payback
yeah however it could also be possible
that they have a shared history
we know that soldier boy is officially
the very first superhero
so i think that he too was part of votes
experiments during the second world war
i definitely think that they will be
linked in some way and
in my opinion soldier boy probably came
over with them from germany
though it could go beyond that now
obviously leave your comments below on
what you think
and if you're new to the channel yeah
don't forget to subscribe as we drop
videos like this every day
and it's the best way to make sure that
you don't miss my annoying accent
now unfortunately it doesn't look like
jeffrey dean morgan will be appearing
all that much in the season
and when asked what was happening with
him kripke told gamesradar
of the many things covert is screwing up
in this world a jeffrey dean morgan
cameo or a jeffrey dean morgan role
may be one of them but if the quarantine
is removed
and a couple of things break our way
then yeah we'll try to figure it out
so things are a bit touch and go at the
moment with him
i feel worse than stormfront looks as i
was really hyped to see the actor come
across
negan is my favorite character in the
walking dead right now
and it sucks that his role in the show
may have to be pushed back
now cindy is also meant to be returning
and we know from what's been said in
regards to the third season
that she is now on the loose and as
dangerous as ever
her fate was one of the most open-ended
things about the second entry
and she's pretty much the show's biggest
wild card at this point
cindy is the person who could bring to
light all of the human experimentation
that would have been doing
and i also think she's gonna be playing
a big part too
nathan mitchell to discuss what was
going to be happening with his character
black noir
and the way that things were left at the
end when talking about season 3 he said
him and maeve are not going to get along
that's pretty evident
it's so interesting because you have
this forced alliance between people
homelander doesn't trust maeve doesn't
trust starlight
noir just fought starlight he definitely
doesn't trust maeve
a train just clawed his way back in he
has this
uneasy alliance with starlight so now
they're frenemies
everybody's crossed it's like this house
that's divided within itself
but still together there are a lot of
interesting undercurrents of the dynamic
that's going to be coming out of season
3. so yeah there are so many things that
could go wrong
and as history tells us empires always
fall apart from the inside
and not because of exterior forces at
least we know
noir is still alive as he's also an
incredible character
that i think they can really do a lot
with even if he gets very little
now as for the storyline beyond the
things that was set up in the second
season
we will obviously also be getting some
real world events that influence the
plot line
when talking about whether season 3
would tackle a pandemic or not
kripke said i can tell you that season 3
without being specifically about covid
we're having a lot of conversations
about the government's response to it
here in the states
and my guess is you'll see that
metaphorically show up
in one way or another we also know that
herogasm will be popping up at some
point
and in the original work this was pretty
much a sex-filled vacation for the supes
in which they got up to whatever sorted
things that little hearts
desired that's pretty much everything
and there's a lot to look forward to
and i'll of course keep you up to date
as we learn more about the ins and outs
of the show
obviously i'd love to hear what you want
to see happen in the series
so make sure you comment below and let
me know more to planning a big character
breakdown at some point
so let me know which one of the seven
you want to see me talk about
if you want something else to watch
after this then definitely check out our
breakdown of the unanswered questions
that we have at the ending of season two
as i think we think we clear up most of
them
now don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel face unbox
set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early and please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat just on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you